if you were the federal reserve chairman
what would you do right now you're
you're in charge
give me the playbook they get three or
four moves how do you get this to
inflation comes down we avoid a
recession oh look if i was the head of
the federal
reserve i would basically
maybe
call a press conference and i would
basically level the american public and
say the party is over the buck stops
with me
interest rates i am the fed is out of
the interest rate manipulation market
we're no longer setting rates rates are
going to go wherever they're going to go
the market is going to determine
interest rates not the fed so we're just
going to take the pressure off
and we are going to start unloading our
balance sheet we're going to start
selling us treasuries we're not just
going to let them mature
we are selling them
um
and basically interest rates are going
to soar
um
and i'm basically going to say look
there's there's no more bailouts there's
no more stimulus so
the government needs to
finally
act responsibly and there needs to be
massive cuts in government spending
there needs to be
i don't know tax hikes and maybe the
government has to default on its debt i
mean if there has to default that's
better than me than the fed inflating so
but
the government can no longer rely on the
federal reserve to paper over its
problems by creating inflation we're
going back to sound money
you know we're going to follow the
original mission of the federal reserve
and and that's it and we're not going to
be political anymore we're not going to
be bailing out politicians and investors
uh we're going to have a free market in
interest rates and we're going to have
sound money
uh even though it's fiat money i mean
we're gonna you know make it as sound as
we can
um
by you know kind of maybe having a de
facto gold peg like alan greenspan used
to talk about having that he looked at
the price of gold and if gold was too
low he knew they were too
too uh tight if gold was too high he
knew they were too easy but i don't even
think they even have to do that if you
if you allow the gov the market to set
interest rates because if the market
sets interest rates the rates are going
to go way up i mean there's no doubt
about that
uh especially if they know the federal
reserve is permanently out of the qe
business that like no matter what
there's no more qe we're never going to
do it again all we're doing is qt
never again when we do qe and the market
knows that
uh but yeah i mean you know it's not
going to be fun i mean i i would be
doing what paul volcker did right i
would be the new paul volcker only the
problem is
the economy is in much worse shape now
than it was when paul volcker was around
in 1980. so the consequences
of having another paul volcker are so
much greater
but the consequences of not having
another paul volcker are also so much
greater because if we don't do the right
thing which is what i would force to be
done right away then what ultimately
happens is going to be so much worse
because i think paul volcker knew that
back in 1980 if he did not get control
of inflation and allowed it to run away
uh it would have destroyed the dollar
and and it would have destroyed the
economy back then and so he did what was
right
and he took the short-term pain for the
long-term gain the fed doesn't do that
now they do the opposite trade they
trade short-term gain for long-term pain
well the problem is the long-term pain
is going to be excruciating and you know
we may be in the long term right you
can't always say yes it's a problem for
the future it's a problem for the future
because eventually that future is your
presence
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time